Have you seen an increase in cancer since the COVID vaccine?
I think cancer rates since the COVID vaccine.
Well, it's dangerous question to ask without the cancels,
but we have had comments from people.
I think we actually just spoke to a person,
we're able to spoke to a person
that we followed a couple of weeks ago that said
that this person and their eight siblings
had to get vaccinated in order to see their dying mother
in hospice.
And within a year, all eight siblings
have a diagnosis cancer.
That's great dramatic.
We've spoken to people in the fold with these kind of comments
that had not, their cancer was in remission.
They got the vaccine.
The cancer came back with a vengeance
right after the vaccine.
The vaccine does have an immune suppression component to it
that can cause that.
There can be other physiological causes to that.
If you went to Google and you searched,
has there been an increased cancer rate since the vaccine?
You get the exact opposite response,
but Google has been filtered in anything that shows,
any studies that have shown different than that
have been taken off of Google.
I've seen multiple studies from Europe that showed
that there's increased cancer rate of people
that have been vaccinated, increased cancer growth
of people that have been vaccinated,
but you'll won't find any of those on Google
because Google is a branch of the pharmaceutical propaganda arm.
So it is, you won't see that on that.
So we have seen an increase,
and I don't know the complete physiology of that,
but I've never been pro-vaccine of any kind,
certainly not that one.